hey what's up guys my name is China
welcome back to my game engine series so
I just got off a plane like yesterday
and I'm super jet-lagged I've been in
Europe for like the last five and a half
weeks so this video is kind of gonna be
a little bit all over the place if you
give me that I'm very very tired anyway
welcome back to my game in this series
last time we talked about transforms
check out that video if you haven't
already and today I'm going to talk to
you about materials we're gonna have a
bit of an introduction to materials why
they exist how we're going to use them
why they just like why we need them in
game engines I'm not gonna make an
in-depth video with like diagrams or
anything I'm gonna save them and just
have that be about materials and
whatever in the future I promise you
guys that I know that I've said it's
gonna be a bunch of in-depth videos if
anyone has a collection of the in-depth
videos I promise to make please post in
the comments by the way because I'm
gonna start working on them like next
week or so but we're gonna have a bit
bit of a basic overview of what
materials are we're gonna quickly jam in
a very basic material system not really
even a material system but just to kind
of give you the idea of how everything
ties together practically and that's
gonna be kind of it for today and then I
think next time we might continue on
with shaders or textures because
textures are also something that I want
to get done but anyway let's talk about
materials like why do we need a material
system so right now let me just maybe
launch our code and we'll see what we
actually have okay so we had this
triangle and we were able to do like
rotate it and move it around and we
basically could move the camera around I
guess and then we had like a bunch of
tiles that we were rendering as separate
objects with separate transforms as what
we did last episode so suppose that we
wanted to make one of those triangles
like I don't know a little like one of
those squares as we kind of decide to
draw each square we want to make them a
different color so how does that work
exactly
well so far we know that shaders exist
as a way to essentially tell our GPU
what to do with data the baguettes how
we actually realize I guess that data
onto our screen right so we have vertex
positions we have you know our screen
kind of coordinates or whatever we need
to draw certain geometry we've given it
a draw command a drop ball to actually
draw like say two triangles to make up
like a square right we put all that data
but how do we how do we actually draw it
where do we put on the screen vertex
shader takes
that and then what how do we shade those
pixels those pixels what color do they
amount to the fragment shader or the
pixel shader deals with that so that's
what a shade that is it's a program
which determines all that and if you
kind of rusty on that check out either
my opengl series on shaders or the
actual shaders i think video in this
series because that was quite
informative as well that's what a
traitor does right so that's great and
we know that what you should be able to
do right now is if i say make the
triangle red you should be able to go
into the shader and actually change the
code and just make it output a flat red
color easy right with this afternoon
blue i'll change some numbers around
suddenly the straightest in that house
red and i think we even called this the
blue shadow but in in the real world we
like to write shaders that are a lot
more flexible than that you don't want
to just write a shader that's like your
blue shader and that's done the reason
is that shaders are it's like a program
right you wouldn't write a program which
is calculates a single number it would
be much better to write a program which
takes in two inputs and then like adds
them together or whatever and then gives
you answer isn't that much more kind of
useful you could have a program which
computes ten plus five right and that's
it that's your program braid it could
compute ten plus five it's amazing but
what if i make a program which asks the
user for two numbers and add them
together how much more powerful
how much more useful does that actually
become same deal with shaders right we
could write a shader that just outputs
read totally fine called the red shaded
gray we got blue shadow i don't have a
red shader but what if I could make a
shader that takes in some data as an
input and then outputs that color and I
could call that shader the flat color
shader right and a lot would do is
taking an input which might be red my
people who might be any color I can
think of and then shades all the pixels
to that color right that would be a lot
more useful wouldn't it and that's kind
of where a material comes in because
what we do is we write our shaders as
flexible as possible or I might be
written by like you know an engineer or
technical eyes or something like that
and then all the other artists so
working on the game who need to be able
to actually make the game look good and
maybe detect artists as well they're
gonna come in and feed data into that
ready-made shader right they don't have
to know anything about the shader they
just know that it takes
these inputs and inputs could be
anything really that define what that
material what that surface kind of
should be like right so that could be
anything from like the color it could be
like a texture which to kind of transit
service could be like other service
properties such as how rough or smooth
is it right is it a metal is it a
plastic one I get into PVR here as well
could be a normal map right which just
defines extra detail so that when we do
our lighting calculations it looks like
it's a lot more detail than it is we
have a lot of different things that we
can actually do there's other things
that are uses as well like light
Direction camera direction all that
stuff is required to be input into the
shader although that kind of stuff is
usually handled by the renderer and not
by the material but you kind of get my
point there's a lot of stuff that we
kind of feed in and obviously you could
be fed in somewhat through the vertex
attributes that's kind of what we've
been doing in a way like for example you
know we use the position of this
triangle I think to actually work out
its color right yes we have a varying
color and that is a color I think at
some point I think for the triangle we
were just calculating the color to be
like positions or something like that
that's done by just you know taking in
the vertex attribute for the position
and then actually calculating you know
which fragment lies waiter plating and
we get all these colors that's fine at
all and we could obviously have a vertex
color right but that obviously is again
something's baked into data what if I
want to be able to change that kind of
on the fly right and that's where we get
the whole data having a bunch of data
and then having a shader and that data
is called a uniform right we have
uniforms which is basically pieces of
data that we can transmit to the shader
app like before we draw and it's done
kind of per draw right and then that way
when we decide to actually draw
something and it needs to actually find
that data you can just access the data
from the uniform and that's it we can
now say that it's gonna be red it's
gonna be blue so that's what a material
essentially is it's a shader which
defines how everything it's the code
that says this is kind of the algorithm
I'm gonna use this is what's gonna
happen to determine that final color but
it needs inputs and those inputs are
called uniforms and that's what a
material is it's a bunch of uniforms and
a shader shader and data that's all it
is and it's pretty much that way in
every game engine that I've ever seen
it's always a shader and a bunch of
uniforms and we might take a look at a
more technical overview of that other
7/8 in depth video but essentially I'm
just trying to put into your heads that
that's that's really all it is obviously
the complexity of these systems can be
enormous because even though we do want
our trader to be flexible as I said we
don't want it to be flexible to the
point of being very slow and doing like
a bunch of if checks to check is this
what we want because you can make an
uber shader essentially which is like
just every possible thing right you can
have one shade of your whole game and
that's all of the possibilities right
but that's somewhat that's pretty bad
like you don't want that and so what
ends up happening in the real world is
an intelligent like shared a compiler
that you've written will essentially go
through the shader and determine what is
actually needed and then kind of grab
all the different building blocks of the
stuff that's needed combine that into a
shader and then just create that as a
shader so instead of having one shader
that can do 300 things you end up having
300 shaders even though you wrote one so
more on that later because we're
definitely had a system like that
sometime in the future it's very useful
but anyway I don't want to sit here
talking for hours um I definitely could
especially cuz my mind is a bit fried
but I want to get in and basically write
something like this but our goal is
gonna be to try and make some of these
squares in different colors and we're
gonna do that by making a material and
then kind of submitting that material
alongside our geometry think we'll
actually submit and then usually what
would happen is if you have like a mesh
or a model class essentially which
contains all of your geometry that you
actually render that also usually has
materials associated with it because
obviously if you kind of look at a game
engine you kind of author your assets in
a way that you're never dealing with
code to this level usually I might feel
like
experimenting or playing around with
stuff usually artists will kind of make
a 3d model and they obviously want to
apply material to it in some sort of
tool and so that model gets linked for
that material right because it would be
very weird if you kind of like yes you
can have materials separate to geometry
but usually that's not the case I mean
think about it you're building this room
and you want to do you want to render it
in your games and this is a wooden table
right you you make the geometry for the
wooden table and then you apply the
wooden material to it you would never
want to separate them because that's
just the way that this is right I mean
if you're building really dynamic stuff
the material might degrade or change
over time let's that there are always
exceptions but the idea is that we want
imagine we have a material with us so
usually those two pieces are tied
together so you wouldn't really just
author a material right there and then
in code definitely can do that that we
definitely will support that but I'm
just trying to show you kind of the
bigger picture of it if I was actually
building a game with hazel or with an
end and how would that work um anyway
we're gonna go in and just literally
play around with this code a little bit
there's gonna be kind of more of a
freestyle you know video where I just
kind of just discuss what I'm doing so
much and we're not really writing final
code but we're just like talking about
concepts and playing around with them
and implementing somewhat of a system
but essentially if we just kind of think
about what we need so we need a material
class or something which called the
shader which again is our compiled
client shader program and then we need
some way to define data for it now again
this system ends up being really
complicated usually because the the data
that we define like what does that
what's to say what data we define how do
we set uniforms properly what happens if
the uniform doesn't exist do we need to
like actually check the shader code
first to see what uniforms even exist so
those are the only ones that we can set
right and then we also need to accept
pretty much any kind of data and then
how do we interface with like uniform
buffers or like Direct X is constant
buffers right well instead of submitting
uniforms one by one we usually submit a
constant buffer we might have multiple
constant buffers because one might be
submitted by the renderer mama committed
by the material huge huge huge task as
usual because game engines are quite
complicated
um and we'll tackle these things slowly
but as I just like to introduce them by
sharing a simple exam
so that people who aren't as experienced
with this won't find themselves in the
deep end as often and will actually be
able to make sense of this so let's dive
into the code and we'll just play around
and see what we can do okay so the
important stuff again is just again if
you get overwhelmed with stuff like this
think about what it actually is
as I've mentioned it before it is a
bunch of code which is our shaders right
we have a vertex shader on a fragment
shader the moment we're throwing that in
a shader and a hazel shader object which
is fantastic that's all we need and then
we have a bunch of data so we're not
actually using uniforms at all at the
moment oh I'm sorry we are for I'm a
vertex shader for like um if you know
through our transform and for our view
projection matrix matrix and that's all
fine but we've never actually used
uniformly I think in the in the fragment
shader so first of all let's just take a
look at what our end goal is I want to
make these let's say I want to make
maybe I'll make two different types of
um square so you saw we had a grid of
squares that's great I want one of them
to be blue one of them to be red right
so what I'll do is so maybe we should
make half of them blue have them read
I'm not sure but basically what I'll do
is the first thing I'll do is find the
right so we'll have the red color
which will just essentially be a color
right now let's take our blue color
because I want to make the red color the
same kind of shade so we'll make red
color and a blue color and they'll be
back for us let's just do this quickly
and then this will be the blue color
will be that's the blue and the red
color will be just point eight point
three point three okay so we've got two
different colors I want to make we can
just literally alternate this so what I
can do is I can say essentially that if
I you know mod 2 equals zero rice is
just basically a sorry small height X so
we're kind of as we go through the rows
every every second one will be equal to
0 right so 0 we 0 1 will be not 0 2 will
be 0 etc
what I'm gonna do for that is actually
set this che
this blue shade his uniform which don't
think we have a uniform at all will do
upload uniform flow for will set this to
be a red color and then otherwise we'll
set it to be the blue color right so we
kind of have an alternating pattern milk
now obviously this is not efficient at
all because usually you would like to
batch together your materials so in
other words you would like to do as few
of these as possible so what I would
actually do is render all the red
squares first then all the blue squares
just want everyone to understand this is
just a test and we're not talking about
efficiency or the optimal way of doing
things but we basically do this and we
end up with an alternating pattern of
colors so let's visit our shared class
and make sure that we have the right
function so we'll have upload uniform
flow for this really needs some work by
the way to straight a class so maybe
that's something that I'll do next
because yeah I mean there's a lot of
stuff that need to be done here high
values I guess I'll copy this come over
here paste this in here we'll get the
location as usual I saw someone leave a
comment about caching the location yes
that can be done that's not a bad way of
just that's a quick dirty way of just
saving some performance usually you
wouldn't usually you'd calculate
allocations ahead of time when compiling
your shader anyway so that's not
something that we're really gonna what
is it flirt for uniform exact what is
the function I can't believe it I
remember this oh it's just for 4v4 FP
nope
or F okay there we go doing this
remember of course and then we have the
location and then is X Y Z and W um yeah
usually you would you would basically
just have a system that reads the shader
positive pauses the shader gets all the
uniform values from that and then
actually like guest locations of all of
those uniforms just right there and then
and then you do that one
that's it that's done they're safe
because the traders never gonna change
right if it does change then you
obviously recompile it and then that way
you also get other bonus things from
that like validation making sure the
shades actually exist making like since
you're aware of the shaders and their
types you know how much how big your
buffer needs to be so that you can store
all of them in a buffer and that kind of
just goes down that road so we'll end up
doing that in the future so I'll call
this my you underscore fellow that's
gonna be name of this uniform okay and
I'll just make this inside the blue
shader right so the blue shade is not
gonna be a flat color shadow and I will
actually go as far as to rename it flat
color just so there's no confusion as to
what it actually is and then blue shader
as well okay so how do we add a uniform
simple we just type in the word uniform
and then the type back for and then the
name of the uniform you understood color
and now what I'm going to do is output
color to BU color pretty simple could
make this effect 3 and just kept the
alpha constant notes 1 as well that's
fine but we'll do that maybe you guys to
try the other way at home let's hit f5
and we should get some kind of
difference in our squares now some of
them half of them essentially should be
blue half of them should be red ok and
there you go so you can see half of them
are red and half of them blue that's
perfect so we've basically introduced a
material haven't we we've got a shader
that is somewhat flexible we can add any
color we want we can easily just add an
I'm giving control to actually change
the color that might be something you
guys could do for homework just adding
home GUI control so that you can
actually play around with the color and
we can do that next time as well but
essentially what we are not with is a
way to actually pick any color we want
and set it into the shader and then
render something and it will be with
that actual value with that red value or
with that blue value which is pretty
cool that's all great but we never want
to do this like
this way essentially right what well we
actually kind of take the shader and
then we upload a uniform float for to it
that's weird
we instead what we want to do is define
some sort of material more or less in an
API that probably looks like this where
we have kind of hazel and I can show you
kind of what a what a like an end goal
API might look like because whatever
we're not gonna make that today but if I
make a material essentially usually I
take a material probably have some kind
of material ref because we'll introduce
some kind of automated kind of reference
and Counting system in the future we but
for now since we're using kind of roll
pointers or you know smart pointers or
whatever let's just pretend that this is
a ref I guess I will show you the kind
of final way basically we can just make
a material where we take well we take a
shader in so this flat color trader
right and you make a material out of
that right and then what this does is is
like typically what this would do is
actually take that shader get all of the
information about what data that shader
needs so in other words the uniforms
specifically the uniforms are applicable
to to actual like materials right so for
example as I mentioned before if we look
at this shader and we decide what
uniforms do I want right yes we could
take all the uniforms which would be
three you'll be these two in the vertex
shader and this one in the fragment
shader not good though because a view
projection matrix that is not how is
that part of a material it's not at all
neither is a transform matrix so maybe
we take all the ones in the fragment
shader in this case it will work but
what if we have like cutting our uniform
uniform back three you know light
direction that's a bit weird isn't it
I mean why is a light direction part of
a material I say this all the time but
when you're designing things make sure
they make sense right this bunny here
which I've basically committed to
picking up the for every episode in this
series
this bunny here this is what's the
material of this does it have anything
to do with where the light is coming
from
they're by the way nor it doesn't it's
just yeah sure the light hits it it
reacts a particular way to the light why
because it's well it's got a material
right it's got some kind of form it's
got a surface property that defines like
you know it's all like kind of fairy
here and actually feels like mines but
anyway it it kind of it has all of that
it's not a material but it doesn't care
where the lights coming from that's not
part of the material right I can't like
changing the light direction does not
change the material that this bunny is
made out of does it right so just make
sure that you kind of think things
through in your head use a whiteboard or
a piece of paper if you need to jot
everything down ask yourself ask someone
else does this make sense to you should
it should the material for the bunny
contain the light direction the answer
is no so because of that it's again you
can't just take all the uniforms and be
like that's it that's what belongs then
no you need some kind of way to decide
which uniforms should be set by maybe
the renderer
so like the renderer I should set the
light direction should set the view
projection and should set the transform
transforms kind of object even though
view projection is per scene and service
life direction but we also have another
group of uniforms which is to do with
the material so we need to take those
uniforms and we need to basically create
enough storage like some kind of backing
buffer that actually stores all the data
that we need and that's typically what
would happen upon constructing a
material once we had that storage we can
we'll be able to do things like material
you know material maybe just set you
know and what are we setting we want to
set the color of the material right to
be you know red color and that's it now
there's also the concept of materials
and material instances which the
material instances are essentially just
an instance of the material because you
might want it to find a base material
for example you know this I don't you
you know I mean like instead of making a
red car because this now becomes a red
color material doesn't it I mean it's
like I've said the materials call it a
red right and then maybe I'll apply to
my mesh so I had like a square mesh
let's just say I had it like a square
mesh right
and then I kind of just say you know set
material or whatever to let you say
material right um or maybe I have an
override material I can supply to the
renderer which says that even though the
mesh might have a material I want you to
override it and set this material that's
useful for like debugging and also other
kind of arounder in cases but anyway um
you know what I've done here is I've
created a red material great that
doesn't really solve anything so what I
might do is have just a flat color
material which is this and then from
there I might create something called a
material instance which is derived from
this material but has a specific set of
data right that isn't kind of that is
unique per object or something like that
so another example might be might be I
have a kind of physically based
rendering metal material that's like
silver right that might be my base
material but different spheres that I
render might have different roughnesses
or they might be a bit damaged so they
might have a different like roughness or
like specularity kind of like map
essential architecture that you apply
the determines certain parts of the
sphere look a bit beaten up right that
would be like a material instance
because the base material is silver it's
like that kind of you know the silver
PPR material that you've created
but then the derived one might have a
few kind of particular things that makes
it unique because obviously you you
wouldn't often render a scene filled
with everything that is exactly in the
same shape it might be the same material
it might be a lot of wood in your scene
right but it you know it's likely that
it's different types of wood or it's
different like qualities like it might
be a bit degraded or whatever so we kind
of end up with an API that someone's
like this and it's something that I've
actually done in the private branch
that's available to patrons by the way
huge thank you all patience makes this
series possible patient alcohols that
they're churn oh yeah this stuff has
already been done there so I've kind of
tested this code and if you want to see
it right now you can just hop sport
series and you'll get access to all this
lovely courage anyway back to this so I
kind of have done this already but
essentially you might have like a
material instance ref which would be
like your actual
you know material instance this would
just be you know the same kind of thing
where we have a hazel material instance
is made from a material and then we can
set certain like colors to that specific
material right but that's kind of it and
then you end up with rendering something
with a particular material instance and
in in this example you know you don't
need to upload uniform flat 4 or
whatever because you've already done
that we would instead if I just kind of
get rid of this card at before now we
would instead go ahead and maybe submit
something we wouldn't use a shader
anymore we'd submit something with a
particular material and then what that
material would do is upon us binding
that material I'm inside render a submit
it wouldn't like the renderer does this
stuff that's fine but ultimately we
basically would find we bind the shader
and that's fine it's all needed that's
all necessary but then the next step for
us would be to actually take that
material instance and bind it and by
doing that what that does is it binds
the shader and sets all of the values
that like Oh sets all of the data that
we've actually are storing as a material
instance and that's like that's just
fantastic that whole kind of system it's
great it you can really extend you can
make it really powerful I might even
like I don't I wasn't planning on doing
this but I could sure maybe next time
this stuff kind of working I'm not sure
sometimes I'm not sure what the best way
to explain some of these things are and
I definitely want to kind of do this in
more of like a formal way of like you
know drawing diagrams and stuff I think
that's kind of important but as we get
into more complex topics in the end and
sometimes it's good to have an example
and I've tried to kind of do that for
you with somewhat pseudocode but also
code that looks very similar to the
final api they were kind of working
towards but ultimately you know you have
kind of different like so i might show
you some of the development branch stuff
because you know mature ancestors
materials all that stuff have been kind
of vital for to get that to work
properly and quickly as well because
again once you have a bunch of objects
that you render with different materials
you end up kind of being able to batch
them together you know so that you kind
of do some render sorting essentially
so that you get all of like the red
squares as I said here and then all the
why because the red squares have the red
material instance
so let's you know when we submit
everything to the render since to the
renderer since we don't render
everything at once you know
hypothetically in a good renderer we
have all that data and then when it
comes time to sort it we can say okay
we'll everything that's red will render
first everything this blue will render
second that way we only bind to
materials Fri we bind the red material
render everything with it bind the blue
material render everything with it
obviously certain shared a property that
the transform still needs to be set
that's fine but at least we're not
setting the color every time every time
we want to render one of these squares
because we are rendering 400 squares we
do 400 material flips that's going to
take way longer than doing less anyway
um I think that's probably about eat in
terms of what I wanted to show you guys
if we just jump back here for a sec
though um textures work the same way
right I mean you could make like a set
texture you don't necessarily have to we
haven't dealt with textures yeah that's
something that we really need to do but
you know if we had a texture or
something like that like we might have
texture we might have like an old beater
map or something we can just set that
basically by just uploading as extra
reference or something like that um in
kind of the same way or you could be bit
more explicit so that you know what
you're actually doing and do like set
texture and maybe you have set texture
set value design API
however you like but um essentially like
it works the same way for textures and
the material or the material instance
with the store a whole bunch of um you
know link references essentially to
textures and then we could basically
render something with a particular
texture so it's it's a really nice
system I really like the whole materials
the concept of material systems I've
always kind of liked it because it it
just it's amazing how much safety it
actually gives you it's almost like
smart pointers in a way like you could
just upload uniforms like you know you
look at kind of a people learning OpenGL
for the first time or graphics
programming for the first time you know
what are they doing usually they create
a shader they'll be probably smart
enough to create like a shader class or
something like that and then an API that
lets them set variables and set uniforms
and they can make
something essentially that ends up you
know validating that making sure stuff
exists maybe if location equals negative
one which means the uniform couldn't be
found
you know they log that or they assert
their so they can debug it that's all
great but having a material system we
can actually like a proper one we can
ask the shader hey give me all of your
uniforms ok occupy this much space ok I
can store them in a buffer and then
upload them when needed or I can like
have a material instance which overrides
that buffer and says you know this this
and that or whatever it's just it's just
amazing because nothing will ever kind
of go wrong with this if you write it
properly and that's kind of what we're
going to deal with see so yeah super
excited for that we need to before we
can actually do this though we really do
need to build up our shader class a
little bit more mean we can't even read
shaders from files at the moment so
that's kind of definitely something that
I want to do the other huge question
that I have for you guys and I have
asked that but I'm gonna ask it formally
right now so listen up do we want to
proceed with making hazel a full 3d
renderer right now or do we want to
focus more on 2d again materials less so
useful for 2d because usually you would
render pretty much everything in a 2d
scene aside from like special effects or
special things with just a single shader
so you don't really need too many
materials you can just have a 2d
renderer which basically renders colors
or textures and shapes that's all you
need
so it will kind of put the stuff on the
back burner which is fine we still need
the way we still need to revisit our
shader class and we still need to 100%
revisit textures so I'll probably do one
of those episodes next but the the real
question isn't I'm I'm I'm gonna make a
poll last time I did I made a poll I
wasn't I really liked it too much
because I I don't know how to see the
results properly I way I saw the results
on my own Paul last time was like watch
the video myself voted for something
then saw what the percentages were I
don't know how many people have I don't
know anything about it I probably Google
more maybe but it just seems where I
couldn't even see it in my analytics so
it's a bit weird but I'll make a poll
once again do you guys want to be go in
a 2d direction and make a cool like
blazing fast 2d renderer and just make
hazel able to make 2d games basically
right now and just polish that up make
it ready to go or should we take a lot
longer and
three around or either way we're gonna
do 2d in and move on to 3d the content
will be there either way obviously I'm
very passionate about 3d about Freddy
and I want to actually make a very good
3d renderer and a good game a good 3d
game engine so either way it's gonna
support both there's no way our
collective might make more sense to do
treat you first just so that just so
that it's finished and you guys can
actually start making games with hazel
and seeing it actually work as a game
engine I think that would be very cool
and obviously it's gonna take a lot of
time a lot less time in a proper 3d
renderer so it might make more sense to
do that but either way and I am gonna
continue the opengl series by the way so
but you will see 3d stuff there so if
you're worried about just this channel
being not 3d at all now for the next six
months don't worry about that because
definitely will be continuing 3d stuff
in the opengl series for sure either way
but if you want that one 2d or 3d let me
know vote in the poll and I'll check the
results next time and probably determine
where we're going but either way we're
doing the shader so don't worry about
that anyway I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please hit the like
button as I mentioned earlier patron
icon full touch the Turner is the best
place to help support this series thank
you to all you people who make this
series possible I will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]